[موسيقى]
لدينا قلبنا فيه ، لدينا أفكار رموزنا
، والحزن والسعادة ، ولا
يمكننا فصلها عنا حتى في
هذه الأيام في الحياة العصرية ،
يمكنك فصلها
ونستخدمها على الأقل كسجادة أرضية
[موسيقى]
في إيران لدينا تاريخ وخلفية من ألفي
وخمسمائة عام
للعيش
في كل منطقة في إيران ، ولكل منطقة
نسجها
الخاص وهي مسألة حياة تعلمون
أنهم يستخدمونها لكسب العيش وهي
قطعة
يمكن أن يكون مفيدًا لكل شيء
معروف في كل مكان في العالم
لأن ذلك هو أعلى جودة
للتصميمات وتاريخ وخلفية
ذلك وبالطبع يتم تجميع كل المواد
معًا
لإنتاج سجادة عالية الجودة وعالية الجودة
إلى  العالم
[الموسيقى]
لذلك لدينا سجادة
هنا تمثل وحدة
الأمم
والسلام للعالم ، كل شخص يمكنه
القدوم لزيارتنا
يمكنه تعلم
كيفية العيش
وستكون المكسرات التي يصنعها
جزءًا  من السجادة وبعد الانتهاء من السجادة ،
سنمنحها كهدية للمعرض
من جناح إيران ،
إنه
عمل معقد للغاية بحيث يمكن للناس أن يشعروا به
وينظروا إليه عن كثب ويكون لديهم
علاقة عاطفية بالسجادة
[الموسيقى]
لقد فوجئوا  وكانوا سعداء
لتعلم شيئًا جديدًا عن
السجاد وكان جديدًا جدًا بالنسبة لهم ، لقد كانت
تجربة جيدة جدًا
لهم ، والدوافع التي استخدمناها
أساسًا هي من تراثنا وفي
الوقت الحاضر في السجاد الحضري نستخدم
كل ما هو أسطوري  والرمز ،
إنها دعوة بسيطة
لتقديم تصميم له قصة
تميل
لك [الموسيقى]